hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited Saga on the Cuban legend
Jose roll Capablanca you'll vote it for
this one so here it is we've covered the
few saga so far we had the Bobby Fischer
saga then we had to make out a tall
soccer then we had the Magnus crossing a
brief saga not an entire saga we haven't
covered the rematch against which were
not around but if you're new to this
channel those are definitely one of the
playlist you want to check out you can
check out all of them but those are
those are really detailed the sagas and
really it would be a shame for you to
miss out on them here it's a bit
different with modern players were
mostly going to cover let's say what
Fisher would cover the palm of the Merc
and trans onal tournament then we
covered the candidates tournament and
then we went over to the World Chess
Championship match against him and Boris
Spassky here we don't have a candidates
tournament as you all know the
candidates tournaments were implemented
in 1948 after the death of Alexander
alayhim but we're still gonna cover a
lot of interesting moments in the life
of the Cuban legend from from his birth
in 1988 until well he is a big match
with Emmanuel Lasker and we're not gonna
be covering his match against Illya him
in this saga as that will be a sort of a
part of Alexander alien saga but as we
already mentioned I did get this so it's
basically three cup of longer books in
one features might just career a primer
of chess and chess fundamentals all
three by josé raúl capablanca
the first one might rest career is the
most important one as we're gonna be
using that one for some interesting
notes by capablanca himself and his
choice of games but also we will be
using for four more historic accuracy
the Casablanca book by famous chess
historian Edward Edward winter really a
very nice book but it's there are a lot
of books on josé raúl capablanca and
it's I don't know I haven't done through
all of them but I did they go through
couple one cos book and the idiot world
winter one and I checked up on some of
the references online for
different moments in his life and it's
interesting that not all the stories are
the same in all of these wealth sources
which is to be expected I mean it was a
long time ago but I will mention one
such story is the the one about how
Capablanca learned of chess and how he
started playing chess it's a story many
of you heard plenty of times but Edward
winter really attack us this story in
his book
so in capablanca zone book my chess
career couple uncle mentions that when
he was four years old he remembers that
he was really bored he didn't really
have anything that intrigued him that
amused him and he I don't he said he was
just playing playing out bored and that
one day he went into into one of the
rooms in the in his house and he saw his
father and his father's friends that
they were both in the military and they
were both soldiers they were well he
says they were like this and they'd that
they were really you know deep in
thought in the moment none of them were
moving and they were just staring at
this board with with the peculiar
looking pieces and Capablanca was raised
not you know to to be intrusive to to
not you know interrupt anyone so he just
sat there and he checked out to the
board which them as well so in in the
cup of Blancas book he story goes that
they finished one game and then blank at
the end of that one game learned how the
pieces really moved then in the second
game when they started capablanca also
learned the well the motives of the game
and what what the the game really offers
and then Capablanca mentions in his book
that when the second game ended that he
said to his father that he at one point
to the game that he moved the knight in
an irregular way not in an L trip like
the knight is moved but somewhat
differently and that this was one of the
reasons that the game went on as it did
but as his father mentions capablanca
has never been
before even seen a chess set nor has
ever seen a game of chess being played
so of course Cup among us father
disregarded this says you know child's
imagination or well but as Capablanca
was really really trying to be
persuasive about this his father he said
he was already embarrassed by his young
child kaboom uncle was four years old at
the time and he said that no that's
nonsense and then capablanca challenged
his father to a game they played the
game and when the game is was over
capablanca says that he doesn't know was
his father
well angry amused amazed because a
couple blanca won the game he played
against his father and this story is
somewhat different then you can find in
some other sources because here it's
portrayed as if the the first game was
played and then they immediately played
the second game and that then then
immediately played the game where a cup
of monk a beat his father but in some
other sources it says that the second
game between his father and his soldier
friend was played on the third day it
doesn't say on the third day of what it
just says on the third day so perhaps it
could mean that between the first and
the second game three days have passed
and then perhaps only couple longer
challenge his father well studying the
game at home who knows but it doesn't
really matter that's something for the
historians the argue are still he's a
four-year-old kid who beat his father
while learning the rules just by looking
at them and not by actually playing
chess so that's incredible as it is and
all of well first the his father's
opponent was very very impressed and
amazed by this feat and then all of the
other soldiers that learned of this
great accomplishment were extremely
impressed and they said that our Blancas
father should take a couple Blancas to a
brain specialist and first he was kind
of reluctant to do so but then I mean
Capablanca did show some then his father
said that okay it's not only chess he's
kind of impressive in other other fields
as well well it's hard to say field as
he is a four-year-old boy but his father
agreed and
took him to a brain specialist and after
an examination a couple blanca mentions
in his book that it was a the tests were
really extensive and boring but at the
end of that test that the brain
specialist said that Capablanca was a
really remarkable four-year-old boy
whose mental capacity far surpasses that
of a regular four-year-old boy and okay
his father was very impressed but one
thing the one thing as his father
mentioned to the brain specialist at
capablanca really enjoyed chest and he
was really really getting into chess the
brain specialist said that with such
vast mental capacity he should not play
chess it could be dangerous for the boy
and his father said okay he will not
play chess and capablanca did not play
chess well perhaps he did in his spare
time or maybe maybe read about it if he
had any books it's hard to say what a
four-year-old boy could have but he did
not have any serious contact with chess
for four years so the first time his
father brought him to the hamana chess
table was that one cup of Blanco was
eight years old and even then he could
only at some points I don't know he
couldn't go there regularly you couldn't
play like whenever he wanted so it was
when his father allowed and this game it
it's it's again from 1901 so here
capablanca during this match is twelve
years of age I believe one of the games
perhaps even this one was played on
couple Blancas thirteenth birthday and
Capablanca his father brought him to the
chess club when he was eight years old
now he's 12 years old so some four years
have passed he has become somewhat of a
player but he is here his opponent is a
very strong player he's the Cuban Cuban
Spanish chess master at the one course
so originally from Madrid but he
emigrated to Cuba and immediately a year
after he came to Cuba he became the
champion of the Havana chess club and he
has been five times national Cuban
champion so the strongest player josé
raúl capablanca could possibly face in
Cuba one course who has the white
pieces and Capobianco mentions in his
book that some of his friends said it
yeah you can take him on you you could
beat him I mean it's possible but
Capablanca knew where his strength was
and what his weaknesses are so
Capablanca strength was as he himself
put it his immense understanding of
chess principles so it this is the most
important thing in chess chess
principles and the other thing is his
extreme memorization skills so this is
something he said that he'd never
practice or anything he was just born
that way so deep understanding of the
principles and excellent memorization
and so one of the things that he truly
enjoyed and truly excelled at was the
endgame but one corso was a very he was
a seasoned player five times Cuban
national champion he was great at the
openings he knew opening see new tactics
in the middle game capablanca knew none
of the openings and one thing I wanted
to mention of course I I don't have a
book of Capablanca know who where he is
a young boy of 12 or 13 I do have one I
don't know if I prepared it it would be
a shame if I didn't yeah I did prepare
it so here we have one photo kappa
blanka when he was very young it's hard
to determine the age it doesn't say but
yeah you can see it in the face that's
the young Kosovo couple Blanca perhaps
when he was 8 maybe maybe when he
finally joined the Havana chess club but
here now of course the the portraits of
the players these are of them when they
are older of 1cor so here is a bit older
as during this match that was organized
between him and josé raúl capablanca
Juan Corso is 27 years old so a bit
older than his young adversary and it
was supposed to be a match where the
first player to reach for victories is
the winner of the match without any
drawers who are not counted something
that is unimaginable today but for good
reasons swim now this is the game it's
really a wonderful game and I decided to
show you this one you might be a bit
disappointed but in the long run you
will not be
but I will get back to that so one core
so has the white pieces and he opens
with E for and okay capablanca does not
know any chess openings but he he's you
know done with the principles he 5 we
have Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to
c4 so the Italian game is on the board
we have Bishop to c5 by capablanca the
Joko piano game and here Quan Corso goes
for B for the Evans gambit and no this
time it is not a joke
b4 was plague and capablanca again he
most likely doesn't know how to refute a
and Evans gambit but he knows how to
refute any gambit there is a saying in
chess every gambit is refuted by
accepting it that's the easiest way to
refute a gambit there are of course
exceptions to this but Evans gambit is
one of those gambit that is best refuted
by accepting the gambit so the ship
capture son before we have C 3 not 1
course so for the price of one point
wants to get rapid development Bishop
back to a5 here if you've ever studied
the Evans gambit or checked it out in
some of the openings book you will note
the responses are either Bishop to a5
Bishop to d6 or Bishop to e7 while all
of these are possible
a5 and d7 are the most probable ones
that you will face over the board Bishop
to a5 this is the move that was
considered best at the time
d4 going for that very nice Center he
captures on d4 and here we have castes
in Capablanca now has has an option
where he wants to develop pieces where
he wants to grab yet another pawn
capturing even another point is not
recommended in the evidence gavotte it
is far too dangerous and you would have
you would really even even with knowing
the best replacement by the engine white
would still be better even in the famous
game
Adolphe Anderson played against John
Dufresne you know the evergreen game if
you haven't seen it I will put a link to
it in the description below it's an
insane game it will be the first thing
you will see even there d3 was played so
black wanted to at least slow down why
it's developed
but here kappa blanka goes for d6 one of
the principles in chess is you have to
of course develop pieces we have Queen
to b3 a standard idea in the Evans
gambit going after the f7 pawn and now
you could defend it with Bishop to e6
but that's just giving back material so
Queen to e7 this is the strongest reply
and couple Blanca plays it we have E 5 D
captures on e5 by Capablanca grabbing
another pawn d5 point is well protected
but by removing the D pawn white can now
gain more development by playing Bishop
e3 it comes with an attack on the Queen
and also takes whole of this diagonal
and here it's very important what you do
with the Queen it's important to keep an
eye on the e5 pawn Queen to f6 was
played in the game by Capablanca this is
the strongest move but just to show that
there are dangerous looking everywhere
if you play something like Queen d7 you
are this is immediately met with Knight
captures on e5 Knight captures and now
rook e1 attacking just the night now
it's pinned f6 and f4 again attacking
the knight and after 97 trying to at
least develop or something you want to
open open up the center and after f5
Bishop to f7 check King to f8 and now
after e6 black will just fall apart
let's say Queen d8 now comes Queen
before you attack the bishop and the f5
pawn it's all over for black such are
the dangers that lurk in the Evans
gambit but ok Queen to f6 this is the
strongest movement capablanca with more
giving more protection to the e5 pawn
Knight B to d2 now white continues
development not that the Queen occupies
the f6 square nice the e4 will come with
an attack on the Queen here Bishop to b6
was played by Capablanca improving his
defense of the d4 pawn and also you
don't want to leave this bishop stranded
on a5 the knight the bishop might become
vulnerable but still knight Knight G to
e7 was the correct reply but without
knowing the opening theory Capablanca
could not have known this but okay
Bishop to b6 and now comes Luke to e1 oh
sorry and now comes Luke 81 piling up on
that e5 pawn you don't you could go 94
immediately but it doesn't work after
after Queen f5 nice
the g3 Queen to g6 and now you have to
go in to see chapters on d4 where you
will grab back material black will not
be able to recapture but it's not
nothing anything forcing of course if
black that's captured then Rukh everyone
wins the game
this bishop is controlling this entire
dia diagonal I you would have to move
and then Bishop captures and after seven
attacks the Queen rook to e8 is a threat
everything falls apart but one Corso has
a different idea he plays rook 81
immediately and now comes Knight G to e7
couple Blanca wants to finish his
development but in this case it doesn't
work here the the best reply for
capablanca was Bishop to e6 and now with
the idea that either you will exchange
captures captures over a queen trade and
the Queen trade is always favourable for
couple Blanca in this position or in any
position after Bishop to e6 you don't
capture rather you go after the Queen
with 94 you get Queen g6 and now after
this very nice tactic Knight captures on
e5 Knight captures on e5 Bishop captures
on e6f captures on e6 and now Knight to
g5 trying to get black to capture the
night so you can capture on e6 black
will simply ignore you and go for a
queenside castle an hour after rook
captures on e5 rook to d5 can be played
and now after C captures black will
continue in development and we still
have this position where Capablanca is
simply up a pawn has a better position
and it will be a very comfortable game
for for Jose role but after this rook a
to e1 he played 90 G to e7 and here
tactics just work in white's favor one
quarter goes 494 we have Queen to g6 and
now comes Bishop captures on e7 King
captures on e7 and now comes Knight to
g5 trying to open up lines now also see
capture sandy 4 is a threat there is now
a triple attack against the f7 pawn
stop f6 makes sense kappa blanka
improves his defense of d5 pawn and also
the f7 pawn is no longer a target but
Queen to a3 check and now you can see
that the bishop and Queen really control
a lot of squares here
so what do you do with the king if you
go King da then 9 f7 check picks up the
rook if you go King to d7 then it's a
bit of a different story but still
you're gonna capture on d4 and after
Bishop captures you will go Bishop to f7
you attack the Queen and now you can't
go Queen f5 Bishop e6 will pick up the
Queen you can go here the rook guards
that you can go here the Queen guards is
d3 see - there's really no point for for
Queen going to c2 and if you try
something like Queen to h6 then you get
96 and black is lost whatever black
plays well there's really no good move
to play but whatever move you make you
get Knight captures on e4 and e4 Knight
captures on d4 Knight captures and now
you are unable to recapture the piece if
you recapture then you get Queen to a 4
check c6 Queen captures here King c7
rook check King moves and Queen d6 will
be checkmate so a lot of hidden dangers
so after this Queen a3 cheffy you can go
King b8 you can go here Capablanca tried
a different approach he decided to give
back some material yes he does have
three points for for the piece that he's
about to give so nice to be four and
okay Queen captures on before with check
but now c5 repelling the Queen Queen to
b3 and now comes Bishop sorry first h6
pushing back the night you don't want to
capture on g5 with this point has then
the FAL falls apart we have 92 f7 and
only now Bishop to h3 back up Blanca and
now the thread is a queen captures and
g2 with checkmate so first we have g3 by
honk or so and the only move Bishop
captures on f1 by Capablanca now comes
Knight captures on h8 would an attack on
Capablanca Queen rook captures on h8 and
now Bishop captures on f1 and here a
couple Blanca is down a piece but he
does have three pawns for the piece so
it's not that big of a deal
Queen to f7 Capablanca now wants to
exchange Queens and indeed if Queen
captures in captures them white is up a
piece but with three extra points it
would be hard to prove anything here
with the piece but after this Queen to
have serve
1cor so had a different idea one course
will play tonight captures on e5 and
this simply wins material by force of
course you cannot capture the night if
you play F captors on e5 then you get
rook captures here and then after King
moves it will simply end in serious
material loss or or in a checkmate
after King goes here Bishop is coming to
c4 you will capture here you will bring
the Queen to f3 not much black can do
here but okay there's a not not much to
be done here as after this rook after
this knife captors on e5
you could also play Queen captures on b3
like an in-between move but it doesn't
work Black has already grabbed a white
already grabbed a pawn on e5 people
simply move the knight back this opens
up a discovered attack which is also
check but you could also go for night g6
it's important to move the knight and
after the King moves like a king d8 you
will only then recapture the Queen pawn
captures on unbe 3 and after the rook
moves you'll go rook here the the pawn
is pinned and whatever black plays you
will start grabbing pawn captures monk
captures now black only has two points
up for the piece but the white will very
soon start collecting more pawns and
black has no no real compensation here
so after this Knight captures an e5 we
do go into the variation that we've just
shown couple Blanca decided to play F
captures on e5 we have rook captures on
if I would check King to f8 was played
by kappa blanka and now Bishop to c4
Capablanca move the Queen Queen to c7
and now comes C captors on d4 here with
the rook being stuck on h8 and with mmm
no development and no contra play there
is very little Capablanca can do he
decided to capture here and after Queen
to f3 host several Capablanca resigned
the game what if you resign the King has
nowhere to go as you can see the bishop
controls this diagonal the rope controls
the D file and the only move for black
is Queen to f7 which will end in Queen
captures on f7
and this will be checkmate so you might
think it's weird I'd start the castle
Blanca saga with a game host the World
Cup Ivanka lost but it's very important
it's very important because in this
match against Cuban champion Juan Corso
Jose will kappa blanka lost the first
two games and then it's extremely
important especially for new players to
see how Capablanca changes his style and
who loses
no more games to Concours oh and
continues this match in a completely
different fashion so we are gonna cover
a couple of more games from this match
just to see how how how you play against
the Cuban champion when you have no
opening knowledge how is this even
possible which will be very exciting I'm
sure and I still haven't decided
everything that we will cover in the cup
o Blanca saga will we go cover a few
games in the in the in his match against
perhaps Frank Marshall we will
definitely check out the the 1911 his
first international tournament in San
Sebastian some of his other notable
games his long negotiations about the
World Chess Championship match with
Emmanuel asked her and such but some a
lot of interesting stuff for sure that
there will also be some very interesting
stories about his first encounter would
you mind I'll ask her how he didn't know
who he was and then he he wanted to you
know say Lasker was having a
simultaneous exhibition and then
Capablanca was not really convinced in
this how Capablanca called him this old
short guy he didn't really think his
moves were all that great but then when
people explained to him that that was
actually world champion Emmanuel last
but then come on I was very embarrassed
but we're gonna get back to that in in
some other videos in this saga so yeah
alright that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it's been very long time
since the last we've shown in Evans
gambit I can't even remember I think it
last time we've seen it in that game
between Kasparov and Annan but that was
that was so long ago am definitely gonna
cover a lot more from the life of the
Cuban legend so you know stay put I
would like to thank Nathan Freeman a
David Stern Joseph Paschal Ian
and Subaru Miele for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
with some other games from the josé raúl
capablanca saga and sorry this video had
a bit longer of an introduction as it is
the first video of the saga thank you
all and I will see you soon